all right so right now the round two of
the draft is well underway john treats
uh joining us now with a special person
who actually knows what it's like to be
drafted yeah we're talking about marcus
nash marcus certainly has fond draft
memories john
yeah guys there's about a half a million
people in town trying to live
vicariously through the draft picks we
got a guy who went through it first
round draft pick in 1998 out of
tennessee marcus nash now you're the
wide receiver coach at gorman but is
this an emotional anniversary for you
it definitely takes me back like you
know just thinking about just the whole
process getting involved in it and
as those picks come up
nobody really knows where you're going
to go you can get calls like we're going
to take you but then all of a sudden
something can happen where it'll push
you back so it's definitely takes you
back and gives a little bit of nostalgia
about about that time and you uh your
quarterback in college is peyton manning
he went in the same draft charles
woodson randy moss on that great 1998
draft but you had to wait till the end
of the first round you're a first round
draft pick forever but
talk about those nerves oh man like you
don't really understand and i feel for
these kids because i tell them all the
time because i train a lot of the
gallery guys for the draft and i just
tell them to be patient like don't get
too caught up on on don't be too high
don't get too low
but yeah no it's a lot of nerves you get
calls and they say they're going to take
you and then something could happen to
where like somebody takes a different
pick and it could push everybody back
down like it was you know
when we came out like randy moss was
supposed to be the higher draft pick and
he was upset he was a first receiver
pick but he didn't go to like the 17th
and
and those kind of things happen where
like these big high-profile players that
are expected to go so high they get
pushed back from one little decision so
nobody really actually knows what's
going on because it's all happened so
fast and it can happen at the drop of
the pack we're so glad the draft is here
and we're so glad that you're here
guiding the next round of draft picks at
gorman so i
thank you so much and congratulations on
celebrating being part of that exclusive
fraternity i appreciate it thank you
awesome send it back to you guys
reporting live john treach live local
now